aujourd'hui manger 5 fruits et légumes
par jour devient compliqué pour de
nombreux ménages selon une étude récente
cela pourrait coûter jusqu'à 16% d'un
SMIC net mensuel pour une famille de
quatre personnes et tout le monde ne
peut pas se le permettre les Français
continueront-ils à manger des produits
frais existent-ils des astuces pour les
payer moins cher
[Musique]
en région Hauts-de-France dans le petit
village de la couture c'est
l'effervescence dans cette exploitation
d'endives une cinquantaine d'ouvriers et
sur le pied de guerre mais depuis
quelques mois le personnel vient
travailler la boule au ventre
ils ont déjà du mal en ce moment à faire
plein de gasoil pour venir travailler et
ils sont soucieux bien sûr de l'avenir
de notre entreprise
aujourd'hui un tiers des 450 000 emplois
de la filière fruits et légumes et
menacé et pour cause les charges qui
pèsent sur les entreprises explosent à
commencer par le prix de l'énergie car
ici il en faut beaucoup pour chauffer
ses hangars faire tourner ses tapis
roulants et conserver les racines des
endives dans ces gigantesques chambres
froides
ainsi environ 2000 m² de de frigo qui
nous permettent de conserver nos racines
une fois arrachées au mois de novembre
ça nous permet de les conserver pendant
toute la saison c'est indispensable
parce que sinon on ferait de l'endive
que sur deux mois dans l'année
et ce n'est pas fini en fonction des
besoins du marché Philippe décongèle ses
racines et poursuit leur croissance dans
cette autre hangar tout aussi énergivore
d'énergie pour pour avoir les conditions
optimales pour faire pousser des endives
ce sont des salles climatisées donc on a
une ventilation
en continu et on a les pompes qui font
circuler l'eau c'est à dire qu'en ce
moment par exemple je suis à 16 degrés
dans l'eau dans le fond du bac et je
suis à 14 14 degrés et demi dans l'air
ça consomme bien sûr de l’énergie des
pompes des chauffe-eau Philippe n'a pas
d'autre alternative pour produire de
l'endive toute l'année à la fin du mois
il doit renouveler son contrat
d'électricité mais cette année son
fournisseur lui propose un tarif qui
atteint des sommets
j'ai pas encore fait ce assez de chiffre
d'affaires pour payer la facture
c'est pas possible je peux me faire
chier à bosser que pour payer ma facture
l'an dernier Philippe payait 260 000
euros d'électricité pour une même
consommation cette année avec
l'inflation il va devoir débourser plus
d'un million d'euros
seule solution répercuter ses charges
sur le prix de l'endive mais le
consommateur sera-t-il au rendez-vous
au delà d'un certain prix il va plus
l'acheter et ça va se retourner contre
nous on va se retrouver en surproduction
et puis c'est la mort de la fille on va
rester avec nos endives et basta
pour éviter de mettre la clé sous la
porte Philippe compte produire lui-même
une partie de son électricité il vient
investir 80 000 euros dans un groupe
électrogène et plus de 200000 euros dans
des panneaux photovoltaïques qu'il
recevra d'ici quelques semaines les
endives ne sont pas les seuls produits
concernés par cette flambée des prix les
exploitants demandent au gouvernement un
bouclier tarifaire pour l'électricité et
le gaz mais pour le moment la requête
est restée sans réponse
selon l'association de consommateurs
famille rurales les prix des fruits et
légumes ont bondi de 11% en un an alors
comment consommer des produits frais
malgré cette hausse des prix certains
Français ont décidé de bouder les
primeurs et grandes surfaces pour se
rendre directement à la source chez le
producteur
[Musique]
celle-ci je vais la cuisiner je vais la
préparer je vais la savourer je suis
venu cueillir pour la qualité qui n'a
rien à voir avec celle qu'on trouve dans
les supermarchés et puis même question
prise et moi je trouve que c'est moi
cher là généralement toutes les deux
semaines j'en ai pour à peu près 10 ans
60 grands maximum 70 euros quand j'en
prends beaucoup plus et si je vais à
Auchan j'en ai au moins au moins pour
100 euros il faut pas attendre à ce que
le gouvernement trouve des solutions
c'est aux gens de changer leur manière
de manger
la France compte des dizaines
d'exploitations comme celle-ci qui ouvre
leur porte aux particuliers ici les
beaux jours 400 clients viennent faire
leurs courses donc là on est dans notre
magasin à ciel ouvert donc là le
principe les gens arrivent le panneau
des récoltes aujourd'hui et le but
brouette et les gens vont directement
cueillir dans nos champs ramasser
directement ses fruits et légumes à la
ferme et une tendance qui prend de plus
en plus d'ampleur en France et qui
s'avère être très rentable
ce qui fait qu'on est moins cher les
clients cueillent eux-mêmes donc c'est
quand même très important
il n'y a pas d'exportation il y a pas de
transport la chaîne de froid nous n'en
avons pas non plus donc grâce à tous ces
postes en moins je pense que nous
économisons à peu près 30%
. une bonne idée pour bien se nourrir en
dépensant moins mais tous les Français
n'ont pas forcément le temps ni
l'énergie d'aller à la cueillette
l'association famille rurale appelle les
responsables politiques à attribuer un
chèque alimentaire à tous ceux qui
n'auraient pas les moyens de consommer
des produits sains pour leur santé
[Musique]